[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur vos chaînes pnt
régionale et sur tv5 monde voici tout de
suite les titres de l'actualité de ce
journal les mouvements de grève en
martinique et en guadeloupe contre
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants ne
faiblissent pas et vous verrez dans le
reportage à suivre devient atv les
barrages routiers installés par les
grévistes ne sont pas sans conséquences
sur la vie d'habitants parfois excédé
tandis que de nouvelles mesures pour
lutter contre la pandémie viennent
d'être annoncés certains départements
comme celui de la haute corse où l'on
retrouvera dans ce journal l'équipe de
télé pas aisées ont renforcé le contrôle
des passes sanitaires vous êtes
récompensé faire un geste écolo et
gagner des cadeaux puis vient c'est la
promesse tenue d'une nouvelle borne de
collecte de verre innovantes et connecté
on vous emmènera à limoges en nouvelles
aquitaine pour la découvrir
on finira cette édition par des images
de nos confrères de 8 mont blanc des
images plutôt insolite de participants
au concours du plus beau au cri de
cochon un reportage qui va vous en
boucher un groin
mais voilà comme je vous le disais à
l'instant dans les titres de ce journal
des barrages routiers ont été installés
par les grévistes martiniquais résultat
lille est totalement bloquée il faut
parfois trois heures pour parcourir une
trentaine de km en voiture car ils
chassent hall diana françois e d'auxi
jean-marc porteront et marlène mec de
via à tv martinique sont allés à la
rencontre d'automobilistes coincés dans
des embouteillages monstres et chez
lesquels on sent un véritable sentiment
de ras-le-bol regarder
des voitures qui avancent au pas ou pas
du tout la journée était noire sur les
routes de martinique aujourd'hui les
syndicats d'étaples et a bloqué les
principaux axes de circulation dès 4h
comme ici à mao ou encore à quévert et à
trinité appel entendu camions et taxi
garé en travers barrage sans oublier des
tables chaises et l'as hier les
automobilistes qui ont pu passer entre
les mailles du filet sont rares pourtant
ils sont nombreux à avoir pris la route
avant 5 heures du matin comme bernard
partie de rivière pilote pour rejoindre
au fort de france elle n'est pas à 16h50
d'olivia pilote et il est peut-être
temps dans le futur a maintenant j'ai un
côté du pont de calais ben je suis pas
contre le mouvement mais c'est mal fait
moi moi je suis arrivé là c'est coeur du
match bloqué je peux pas le boulot c'est
pas ce que je vais faire faut bloquer
les points stratégiques pas la petite
population locale a subi c'est tout je
pars disait le subit
tant pis pour moi à moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord pour la mobilisation
et je suis là depuis à 6 heures je
comprends tout à fait les représentants
syndicaux ont été reçus par le préfet
dans la matinée et par le président du
conseil exécutif de la ctm en début
d'après midi ici à fond là et ce sont
les pompiers qui bloquent la circulation
pour peser sur ces négociations et
porter une nouvelle fois les
revendications de l'intersyndicale
aujourd'hui nous avons voulu faire
comprendre aux autorités que nous sommes
présents nous disons de respecter notre
choix respecter le choix de la
population
nous ne sommes pas le vaccin parmi nous
il ya des gens vaccinez vous demanderont
le libre-arbitre hockey et nous disons
nous aussi se passe a dit m diskin
discrimination sociale voilà nos
revendications pour lire
en attendant sur la route certains ont
opté pour une petite sieste de troncs
préféré enfourché leur vélo pour arriver
à bon port
tandis que plane impossible reconfirme
ans que le nombre de contaminations
s'accélère sur tout le territoire
les contrôles des passes sanitaires et
je vous disais dans les titres
s'intensifie un peu partout en france
comme en haute corse et pour cause le
département compte 50 nouveaux cas par
jour de covile 19 des contrôles qui ont
pour but de sauver les fêtes de fin
d'année comme l'expliquent le préfet de
haute corse françois ravier au micro de
ville pierre ichi de télé pas aisé sur
place
faire cette opération aujourd'hui c'est
dire
compte tenu de l'espace nous avons
maintenant malheureusement c'est dire
que si on prend les mesures maintenant
il faudra sans doute attendre trois à
quatre semaines au moins pour arriver à
une stabilisation dans trois à quatre
semaines on est juste à côté des fêtes
de noël est ce qu'on souhaite aussi
c'est que les gens puissent passer les
fêtes de noël tranquillement avec une
vie russe qui aurait très sensiblement
diminué c'est ce qu'on espère c'est le
prix de cette cet effort collectif c
voilà au moment des vacances de noël
quand les gens auront envie de se revoir
se retrouver ne pas avoir oublié les
gestes barrière avoir fait descendre les
taux d'incidence est le nombre de clubs
de cas contaminés c'est tout l'objet des
contrôles qui commence qui se renforce
depuis ce soir
et puis autre chose dans l'actualité
vous le savez peut-être il sera interdit
à partir du mois de mars prochain
d'utiliser des chauffages extérieur jugé
extrêmement polluant et c'est cette
mesure qui est loin de plaire à tout le
monde que nous allons aborder maintenant
avec un dossier brûlant suivi par alix
fourcade à tele7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest à bordeaux
on ne verra bientôt plus de chauffage en
terrasse en france on dénombre 800
terrasse à bordeaux dont 20% de chauffer
les professionnels s'inquiètent avant la
fatidique date de l'interdiction le 31
mars 2022 idée un peu saugrenue pour moi
je suis pour l'écologie mais là je
comprends pas trop qu'on tape le temps
sur les restaurateurs
ce n'était pas la bonne période
j'aimerais bien mettre des bâches des
grands parasols
afin de protéger et protéger les gens
qui veulent manger à l'extérieur
aujourd'hui j'attends une réponse de la
mairie
concrètes parce que je leur ai posé
plusieurs fois la question et ils ne
répondent pas on n'est pas en question
le dogme ego logique même si on pourrait
en discuter sur l'empreinte carbone
aurait pu faire aussi le choix d'une
électricité qui non carbonées plutôt que
le gaz enfin on aurait pu faire des
choix un peu plus souple et puis
accompagner de manière un peu plus lente
cette transition maintenant on est
devant le fait accompli on va bien
évidemment se plier à la règle mais il
faut savoir que ça risque d'être un peu
compliqué économiquement pour aplanir
les tensions la mairie réunit tous les
mois une commission terrasse avec les
restaurateurs on a déjà mis en place la
charte des terrasses à gambetta donc
voir en effet les alternatives pour
l'année prochaine ce qui pourrait se
passer et comment mais ils vont être
très étonné des plaids à mon avis vont
suffire largement en france la
suppression des terrasses chauffées
permettrait d'éviter l'émission d'un
demi million de tonnes de co2 par an
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
entre les 16 à 20% de français qui ne
savent pas se servir d'internet et le
fait que 40 % du territoire n'est pas
encore couverts par la fibre optique on
est encore loin de la france un pays
100% connectés souhaitée par le
gouvernement
alors en attendant il existe des moyens
pour lutter contre cette fracture
numérique comme a freeze dans la somme
des précisions clair et net 2 0 montbron
de wéo la chaîne de la voix du nord
juste vous demander de chercher le fup
de la sécurité sociale ameli.fr faire
une recherche sur le web peut paraître
évident du moins pour certains pour
d'autres manipuler un outil numérique
est presque une source de stress il y en
a qui sont sujettes dessus slave le
matin son son ordinateur moi c'est pas
une chose ni le téléphone c'est deux
choses que
j'utilise le moins possible avec tout ce
qu'on voit maintenant on sait jamais où
on va comment ça peut être réutilisé et
tout ça crée un compte à la banque ou
les choses là où ou même les impôts pour
que pour payer ses impôts sur leurs
trucs maintenant il faut pouvoir pour
faire apprendre à tout faire sur
ordinateur c'est la mission d'alison
chrétiens médiatrice numérique elle
anime aujourd'hui un atelier a freeze
petite commune de 190 habitants dans la
haute-saône est ce qu'à votre avis c'est
bon signe de l'assurance-maladie
création d'une boîte mail prise en main
d'un clavier pendant deux heures elle
distille à ses élèves du jour de
précieux conseils il est important
d'apprendre les bases et aussi de leur
donner confiance parce que souvent les
personnes n'ont pas confiance en elle et
ont peur de mal faire alors nous notre
rôle c'est de vraiment de de les mettre
en confiance les mettre en sécurité de
leur donner les clés pour réussir à
naviguer sur internet seraient nous
savoir surfer sur le web est devenu un
enjeu essentiel à l'heure de la
dématérialisation
impôts sécurité sociale pôle emploi
d'ici 2022 l'état prévoit la
numérisation de toutes les démarches
auprès d'un service public une
transition qui pourrait bien aggraver la
fracture numérique notamment dans les
communes rurales
on a huit cent mille personnes
aujourd'hui dans la région de transe qui
sont en difficulté avec le numérique et
on en à entre 150 et 200 milles sur le
département de la somme le numérique
s'il n'est pas accompagné est un facteur
d'exclusion aujourd'hui si vous chercher
un travail mais que vous ne maîtrisez
pas le numérique c'est comme il y a cinq
ans et c'est toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est l'ours exactement le
même problème lorsque vous vivez en
milieu rural et que vous n'avez pas le
permis de conduire lancée en septembre
dernier le dispositif autonome a déjà
permis à près de 80 samariens de
s'exercer sur ordinateur ou tablette
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
il ya 32 ans l'onu signé la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
qui reconnaît protège ces droits-là des
droits que les principaux intéressés ont
visiblement bien intégré la preuve dans
ce sujet de mathilde de franck ou de tv
78 la chaîne des îles et le regard d une
journée pour sensibiliser aux nombreuses
injustices subies par les enfants en
france et dans le monde à montigny le
bretonneux les enfants étaient nombreux
ce mercredi 24 novembre à l'hôtel de
ville au programme des animations de
sensibilisation menées par les équipes
d'animation des accueils de loisirs que
du conseil municipal des jeunes comme
des plaques où les enfants pouvaient
dessiner ce que représente leur droit à
leurs yeux scellé droit que normalement
tous les enfants devraient avoir être
soigné avoir une nationalité
être coté être protégés avoir une
famille tous les enfants ont droit bah
de manger à leur faim et de boire la
tasse droit à une famille on a le droit
d'avoir une nationalité les enfants
pouvaient également planter des fleurs
aux couleurs de l'unicef et de
l'organisation des nations unies au pied
de l'arbre des droits de l'enfant y aura
donc ces trois lettres non convention
universelle des droits des enfants qui
vont être
je vais être fleuris aux couleurs de
l'onu et de l'unicef donc bleu et blanc
des quiz des mots mêlés ou encore un
memory pour en apprendre plus sur leurs
droits un enjeu important pour la ville
de montigny le bretonneux qui fait
partie du réseau villes des enfants
depuis 2010 est le considérant à
montigny que la jeunesse est une
richesse richesse importante pour le
pays pour l'avenir et qu'on doit
vraiment beaucoup investir pour 7 pour
pour nos enfants pour la jeunesse une
journée des droits de l'enfant plus que
jamais nécessaire selon l'unicef la
crise sanitaire fait peser des menaces
sur la santé la sécurité et le bien-être
et l'avenir des enfants ces derniers ont
vu leur quotidien bouleversé par le
virus avec la fermeture des écoles les
différents confinement ou encore l'arrêt
des activités physiques ou de loisirs
des faits qui vont creuser davantage
encore des inégalités existantes
voile et puis cette fin de semaine
l'édition locale du point consacré à
lille comme vous le voyez sur cet écran
la ruée vers l'île avec justement la
revanche des ch'tis depuis le
confinement liés au co vide lille
connaît un grand regain d'attractivité à
papier très intéressant de geoffroy de
fresnes et d'audrey emery et puis vous
le verrez dans cette édition spéciale
lille pour ce géographe qui s'appelle
laurent chalard la métropole profite
d'une économie florissante mais doit
encore améliorer son image
également un papier sur le bri flop
comme on l'appelle malgré sa proximité
avec londres la métropole de lille peine
à attirer des investissements
d'outre-manche vous le lirez également
dans cette édition locale du point avec
pour terminer un papier imaginons un
futur une agence d'urbanisme et un
architecte construisent la métropole de
lille ii
2051 c'est déroutant wolverine voilà on
ouvre une page environnement dans ce
journal nous savons tous le recyclage
participe à la préservation de
l'environnement alors comment nous
encourager à trier davantage et bien je
vous en parlais dans les titres une
initiative innovante et connectés nous
incite à mieux collecter le vert on nous
récompensant ça marche toujours
plusieurs collectivités ont équipé leurs
bornes de tri sélectif de ce nous au
dispositif alors comment ça marche
explications à l'image de christophe
encore gardé depuis maintenant deux ans
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux comme
georgia à venir déposer leurs emballages
en verre dans ce container et pour cause
avec ce petit boîtier des points sont
crédités sur son téléphone grâce à une
application je prends la bouteille et là
vous allez voir
voilà donc à chaque des pôles en fait il
ya le petit point qui apparaît ici et
qui va en fait déclenché chez pour moi
le point donc sur l'application avec ses
points récoltés georget a pu bénéficier
davantage ou de bons de réduction chez
des commerçants
c'est un commerce alimentaire en fait de
produits locaux et avec une offre qui
m'était proposé parking j'ai pu avoir 10
% de réduction sur la totalité de la
facture
florian utilisent l'application depuis
son lancement en 2019 et lui aussi
profitent des offres proposées sur
boisseuil belle mx le restaurant qui est
pas loin propose par exemple un dessert
maison au choix offerts pour 30 points à
l'achat du manu burger la la coiffure
vous avez à la boutique 10% de remise
sur des prestations ces petites
récompenses ont eu un véritable effet
incitatif auprès des habitants de
limoges métropole qui installé plus de
200 bornes connectés dans les 20
communes de l'agglomération on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une augmentation
par habitant de 2 kg par habitant et par
an de l'apport du verre donc si on
considère qu'on a eu une année blanche
avec l'aco vide c'est quand même une
belle évolution pour inciter les
habitants à davantage utiliser les
bornes et son application limoges
métropole a mis l'accent sur la
communication un investissement gagnant
pour la collectivité et l'usagé pour
nous on diminue notre tonnage en déchets
dans notre incinérateur on recycle le
vert qui recyclable à l'infini
donc ça c'est aussi bon pour la planète
et c'est bon pour le porte-monnaie de
l'usagé un porte monnaie bien rempli
puisque depuis le lancement du
dispositif klink 18000 euros de
réduction ont été proposés dans les
commerces locaux
voilà offrir une seconde vie aux
anciennes gares c'est le souhait et
l'idée dorénavant de la sncf avec son
projet mille et une gare
lancé il y a trois ans maintenant
l'entreprise propose d'ailleurs 80 mille
mètres carrés de locaux vacants sur tout
le territoire à convertir une deuxième
vie pour ces lieux un peu délaissés
comme l'ermitage et à combourg en
ille-et-vilaine où claire viallon de trc
rendu au regard des
prendre son train et chine et quelques
objets c'est désormais possible en gare
de l'ermitage il y avait l'ombre elle
l'ombrelle que elle elle va être regardé
depuis le 10 novembre la recyclerie
l'échappée belle ouvert ses portes dans
l'ancienne gare un lieu atypique qui a
séduit mélanie l'une des porteuses du
projet ça fait partie du patrimoine
de l'ermitage et des alentours elle et
ses chargées d'histoire et
donc c'est chouette de pouvoir ouvrir
une recyclerie avec des valeurs
justement de vie locale voilà dans un
bâtiment comme comme la gare c'est grâce
à l'appel à projet mille et une gare que
cet espace a pu voir le jour après un an
de travaux les 120 mètres carrés ont
complètement été réaménagé on a essayé
vraiment d'en tirer le maximum en
compartimentant nos espaces de vente et
c'est plutôt pas mal au final parce que
ça ça me permet de dissocier des
ambiances différentes d'un étage à
l'autre la gare de l'ermitage est la
première du département à connaître une
seconde vie mais elle pourrait bien
donner des idées à combourg voilà donc
là on est dans un espace de 92 mètres
carrés
c'était un ancien logement de chef de
gare ces locaux sont disponibles sur la
plateforme mille et une gare l'appel à
projet est toujours en cours est ouvert
à tous les habitants et à tout type de
proposition on a essentiellement des
comores king des des cafés de la
restauration de l'épicerie bio en
circuit court donc on sent que tout ça
ce sont des enjeux qui importe et qui se
développe sncf gares et connexions et
une enveloppe maximum de 200 mille euros
pour les travaux et l'entreprise et
surtout attentive au projet ancré sur le
territoire ce qui nous intéresse c'est
vraiment la dimension sociétale des
projets qui sont installés dans les
gares on recherche pas de rentabilité
immédiate mais on recherche vraiment à
dynamiser le territoire la gare de
combourg attend donc ses nouveaux
locataires sur le département deux
autres projets de réhabilitation vous
voir le jour très prochainement en gare
de vern sur seiche et de montfort sur
meu
voilà et si demain nous devenions tous
antheaume ofaj autrement dit est-ce que
nous pourrions tous nous nourrir
exclusivement d'insectes dans tous les
cas l'entreprise agro nutrition prépare
voilà dix ans que ce laboratoire en
haute-garonne travail sur cette question
et mathis gardant de la dépêche a
rencontré pour nous son directeur à
saint-orens de gameville regardez
une de nos spécificités
c'est qu'on est pour le moment la
première et la seule entreprise en
europe à avoir le droit de
commercialiser nos insectes pour
l'alimentation humaine les insectes
c'est vraiment une solution qui va
permettre de produire des protéines dans
un monde avec des ressources limitées
un besoin de protéines plus important
voilà il sachez qu'il existe plus de
1900 espèces comestibles d'insectes dans
le monde sur ce bonne appétit pour ceux
qui sont à table faire du sport dans un
fauteuil c'est possible ça s'appelle le
ea sports autrement dit le sport depuis
un ordinateur
d'ailleurs certaines disciplines virtuel
comme l'aviron le cyclisme pourrait même
être médaillables ou jeux olympiques et
oui d'ici sept ans en revanche pas le
football pourtant on y trouve deux
sacrés champions comme il y est ce que
céline ersilia de tl7 la chaîne de la
loire à rencontrer et vous allez voir
son quotidien sort quelque peu de
l'ordinaire
à 19 ans il y est c'est un athlète
professionnel son talent réside dans ses
pouces depuis le mois de mai il est
joueur professionnel pour le psg ea
sports pour cela il doit jouer à fifa un
jeu qu'il pratique depuis tout petit et
en fait je joue beaucoup et mon oncle
quand j'étais petit mais tacle des
scores et le faisaient pleurer tout le
temps j'étais dégoûté et en fait j'ai
voulu me venger plus tard et du coup
j'arrive à le battre et du coup bah
c'est un peu lui qui m'a motivé à être
pro sur ce choix parce que après j'ai
pas lâcher le jeu et ensuite je fais
beaucoup beaucoup de tournois et je me
disais pas pourquoi pas devenir joueur
pro il y as a remporté plusieurs
compétitions il a aujourd'hui un contrat
d'un an et gagnent entre 1000 et 3000
euros par mois toute la semaine ils
s'entraînent en moyenne cinq à six
heures par jour alors oui il suffit de
jouer mais pas seulement on joue à la
com comme tout le monde c'est à dire que
voilà on s'est tous faire n'est pas si
ray etc mais il ya aussi beaucoup de
l'analyse c'est à dire qu'on va essayer
de voir par exemple compte des joueurs
pros
qu'est ce qui permet de contrer sa
tactique quelle formation va-t-il jouer
pour quelles raisons la plein de choses
qui rentrent en compte en fait et on va
s'entraîner beaucoup avant les tournois
pendant ces moments là ils sont trois en
france a représenté le club parisien ils
représentent plus psg et ont pour
objectif de ramener le plus de points
lors des matches et cerise sur le gâteau
le job permet de faire quelques séjours
à clairefontaine et même de jouer avec
les stars du club ce qui m'a faire c'est
je contacte bas et d'alba
donc a choisi mon équipe c'était le
dilemme c'est à dire qu'on ose à un
contre un contre eux et je choisissais
notre équipe et d'agouazi choisir la ss
et j'ai pris la ss et il m'a dit un
moment il court il est plus lent que moi
comment ça se fait qu'ils coûtent plus
de commandes parce que je vais marquer
un but avec hamouma donc il était
dégoûté et à jouer comme ça toute la
journée il ya ça a peut-être trouvé le
job de rêve en tout cas moi j'ai trouvé
un super coach pour m'apprendre à jouer
à fifa adrien je te parle quand tu veux
je vous emmène maintenant voyage dans ce
journal entre amsterdam londres et san
francisco avec catherine l'héroïne du
premier roman du journaliste yves bigot
par ailleurs directeur générale de tv5
monde un roman initiatique au coeur des
années 60 où une jeune hollandaise va
croiser les figures emblématiques de la
pop culture et du rock une ambiance et
une époque que l'auteur connaît bien
christophe rigaud la rencontre et
regarde
la musique les années 60 les états unis
on retrouve un peu de toutes les
passions d'yves bigot dans son premier
roman 4 aïn l'histoire plutôt
rock'n'roll d'une jeune néerlandaise
obligés de quitter précipitamment son
pays elle va être amenée suite à un
scandale de moeurs qui implique son père
à être lâché sur les routes donc entre
l'été 1966 et l'été 1968 donc en plein
coeur de la contre-culture donc les
provinces d'amsterdam qui ont inspiré
mai 68 le swinging london avec les
débuts de pink floyd et puis dallas la
beatlemania et évidemment et elle
atterrit à un san francisco juste avant
le fameux était de l'amour où elle y
découvre le mode de vie des des hippies
et l'heureux leurs rêves le roman d'yves
bigot nous plonge dans une période
fascinante où la société s'est
profondément transformé dans les années
60 c'était la libération des femmes et
c'est ça qui était nouveau c'est ça qui
était révolutionnaire c'est la manière
dont elle faisait des choses qu'elles
n'étaient pas censés faire dans la
société jusque là et donc c'est ça qui
est passionnant
un roman haletant qui résonne
particulièrement aujourd'hui alors que
la jeunesse est aux prises à de nombreux
défis comme l'écologie l'anti racisme ou
la lutte contre les inégalités des
combats qui sont tous nés dans les
années 60
tout à fait autre chose maintenant dans
ce journal ou partons annecy où comme je
vous le disais en titre chaque année est
organisé un concours de couinements de
cochon luca ruch de luxe montblanc et y
assister écoutez c'est du lard numérique
dans le cochon tout est bon et cela
passe aussi par l'imitation
[Musique]
on marche de la 15e fête du caillou
annecy un concours de cris a été
organisée comme chaque année tradition
oblige on s'appelle la fête du cai ont
donc caillons c'est l'homme aux cochons
savoyards et pour faire une fête autour
du cochon faut à tout prix bien concours
de cri du cochon
on avait on a des bons de bons
prestataires de bons prestataires qui se
sont enchaînés au micro pour partager
leurs tentatives d'imitation
de son côté c'est carton plein pour
pascal qui remporte le concours bon pas
sans un certain entraînement
[Musique]
et comme l'amusement est un prétexte
l'ensemble des bénéfices réalisés par
l'association organisatrice seront
reversés auprès d'action humanitaire
voilà et puis du sport maintenant avec
l'arrivée en début de semaine des
premiers bateaux de la 15e édition de la
transat jacques vabre un moment
immortalisé par la caméra de tom gagne
ou pour vyas atv martinique saluons
l'exploit de franck cammas et de charles
caudrelier vainqueur dans la catégorie
ultime que relier le havre à fort de
france en seize jours une heure 49
minutes et 16 secondes pas voilà donc
pour les puis le magazine sort session
nous relaterons souvent les reportages
dans cette édition car le surf devient
sport olympique à tahiti en 2024 pour
les jeux de paris et sur cessions
consacre ce mois ci un portrait à un
homme qui se définit comme un amoureux
de la nature qui alterne entre surf
méditation au sommet des montagnes et
refonte esthétique de ses clients le
docteur alexandre rasul yar auquel vsd
par ailleurs consacre également un long
papier et une interviewe voilà le surf
au programme du sport dorénavant en
france et dans son jt des territoires
voilà et avant de se quitter je vous
propose de découvrir les incroyables
images prises par fabien bonilla et
alexandra marangoni de monaco info un
fabuleux spectacle a lieu dans le ciel
monégasque le 19 novembre dernier pour
célébrer le jour de la fête nationale
193 drones ont offert un étonnant ballet
d'une douzaine de minutes à des
spectateurs totalement émerveillé comme
vous le voyez sur ces images
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivi sur vos
chaînes régionales et sur tv5 monde au
revoir à tout ça très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir
[Musique]